mois déjà la première question c'est
qu'est ce qui vous a amené à être
bénévole par exemple daniel vous qu'est
ce qui vous a mené et bien c'est le fait
que dès ma jeunesse on m'a appris à
regarder autour de moi et
particulièrement les gens en difficulté
et j'ai senti que je ne pouvais pas
vivre que pour moi même et que je
trouverai vraiment de quoi épanouie dans
ma vie et aider les autres en engageant
et vous attendez à huy
alors là vont au départ ça ça a commencé
lorsque j'étais adolescente et que
j'allais aider mon curé à faire le
catéchisme par exemple voilà
et puis lorsque j'étais lycéenne
j'allais voir des vieilles personnes
abandonnées et à qui j'apporte est un
peu de réconfort
voilà on en discutant en leur apportant
des petites douceurs etc
je ne vois pas de moment de ma vie où je
n'ai été engagée alors là vous êtes
engagés sur tous les lieux à ce que vous
êtes engagé avec avec lui et c'est un
engagement civique a été gelée dire pas
depuis 2002 mariage les deux pieds parce
que votre rencontre dans presse vous
étiez déjà engagées ou à l'époque lui
même en véritable engagement a commencé
en 68
avec la création du syndicat dans
l'entreprise où je travaillais et très
vite il est arrivé à tours
l'implantation de maïs et là on a
rencontré l'abbé pierre on a rencontré
la pauvreté l'extrême pauvreté et du
coup on s'est orienté vers le soutien
vers la solidarité
et pourquoi cette envie de d'aider les
autres d'aller vers les autres sans rien
12 puis ça nous questionnent nous mêmes
moi je peux dire que ma fondamentalement
on est chrétien aussi un et l'évangile
nous dit d'aimer nos frères je pense que
c'est pour moi c'est une grande
motivation mais en même temps je peux
dire que c'est également un engagement
politique parce que je me situe comme
citoyenne et je pense qu'on a des
responsabilités les uns auprès des
autres et que ces choses ainsi
lian ont fait que c'était presque
inévitable que je que je m'engage leur
s'est donné du temps si on se donnait
soir ah oui sûrement
sûrement mais contrairement à ce que
pour penser des gens qui disent oh là là
ce que vous faites et c'est fatigant et
puis c'est dur pour rencontrer de la
dureté de la difficulté
ce qu'on oublie toujours de dire c'est
la joie qu'on en retire parce que les
rencontres avec les autres c'est
extraordinairement réjouissant et je
pense que on reçoit autant qu'on donne
peut-être même plus alors reçoit mais
aussi on arrive à fait ont fait valoir
ces qualifications peut-être parce qu'on
apporte de l'aide est ce qu'on apprend
aussi à oui beaucoup
on apprend beaucoup d'abord on apprend à
écouter l'autre à sortir de soi et à ne
pas tourner sur son ego et puis les
autres nous apportent leur monde
par exemple je pensais au mouvement atd
quart monde qui nous a aussi orienté
vers les très très pauvre ce le sous
prolétariat le quart monde justement on
a découvert un monde qu'on ignorait
totalement
c'est un monde qu'on n'aurait jamais
approcher si on ne s'était pas engagé
auprès d'eux un monde qui a sa culture
propre et qu'on peut mettre en parallèle
avec les cultures dominantes et s'est du
coup on essaie de voir quelle quelle est
la bonne et il la réponse est pas
forcément la culture dominante qui est
la bonne
qui est qui la baule culture à l'oreille
quand on fréquente ces personnes là et
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya d'autres d'autres
horizons et ses autres horizons sont des
fois extrêmement déroutant pour nous
nous ouvre notre notre esprit notre
réflexion et ça ne sais que c'est
extrêmement positif
c'est un enrichissement personnel c'est
se jouait finalement c'est ça enfin oui
par exemple on nous dit souvent pourquoi
est-ce que vous êtes entrés dans le
mouvement du nid
le monde de la prostitution c'est un
monde qui nous était totalement étranger
et on pourrait dire qu'on est entré par
hasard
encore que le hasard on peut discuter
sur ce que ce que c'est des gens nous
ont entraîné là parce qu'ils étaient
engagés eux mêmes mais c'est pareil dans
ce monde de la prostitution on a
découvert un monde dans le monde
c'était extraordinaire des personnes
qu'ils ont d'abord souffert énormément
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
quand on dit que les personnes
prostituées qui vont par plaisir ou
parce que c'est plus facile etc
mais non on a découvert des origines de
gens qui ont traversé des vraies galères
et puis aussi des richesses
insoupçonnées
la preview 6 richesse et parce que
souvent les gens quand ils ont une
activité
il pense à l'enrichissement ou
simplement finalement à vivre à vivre de
leur travail
là le bénévolat c'est vraiment ça c'est
donner son temps et finalement c'est pas
le cas non plus mais on gagne pas
d'argent en tout cas quoi qu'il dise on
nettoie aussi donner son nom et même
donner son argent parce que nous par
exemple à chrétiens migrants
ça nous arrive de payer une chambre
d'hôtel quand les gens font à l'arrêt le
soir donc effectivement y'a pas du tout
du tout d'enjeux financiers
personnellement je suis resté à la
maison donc j'avais du temps je m'étais
fait le pari parce que j'étais plutôt
contre le mariage quand je me suis marié
de ne pas devenir une ménagère popote et
donc j'ai toujours été fidèle à sa c'est
à dire que j'ai ouvert les yeux sur
l'extérieur et une fois que j'avais fait
mon travail
j'avais du temps à donner à d'autres des
langues heureusement il n'y a pas de
regrets parce que ça rejoint exemple sur
le temps long ah oui justement on est à
l'âge des bilans parce que on n'est
quand même pas très loin de la fin de
notre vie
et moi je me dis que je regrette rien
vraiment quelquefois je m'étais dit je
me remettrai au travail dans les enfants
auront grandi et c&g j'en ai pas vu
l'intérêt j'ai eu j'ai acquis à
l'intérieur de ça une grande liberté
personnelle et une joie de vivre
j'ai conquis une joie de vivre à
l'intérieur d'un monde qu'on pourrait
dire et 3 le monde d'une femme au foyer
et
g à l'heure des bilans je me dis que je
ne regrette rien absolument
et vous si vous faites un bilan en fait
on peut pas dire aussi qu'à encore
tellement de choses à faire
ce quand on est dans un secteur
associatif et quand on s'engage on me
dit c'est pour résoudre des problèmes je
démens c'est parce enfin si ça qui est
pas désespérant peut-être je ne sais pas
mais alors ce conseil après 60 ans de
réflexion sur ces questions là c'est
qu'on n'arrivera pas au bout d'une de la
nécessité de s'engager pour vivre
ensemble d'une façon acceptable et ce
qui est réjouissant c'est que l'on sort
seulement de la rencontre des gens
fabuleux mois nous ont par exemple on a
beaucoup fréquenté l'abbé pierre
on a parlé des heures avec lui pour nous
ça a été une richesse extraordinaire
après on a rencontré jacquard alors
jacques hubert aquin on a rencontré
aussi leur les anchois sereine berg à
tas de gens comme ça très brillant qu'il
y était engagé aussi dans les mêmes
combats et c'est fabuleux
c'est quand vous dit tout à l'heure
ben oui mais or on se bat aussi pour des
résultats c'est vrai mais les résultats
c'est pas forcément palpable dans le
sens on n'a pas révolutionné le monde
on n'a pas changé le monde on n'a pas
appris le monde sur nos épaules
on en a pris notre part comme disait
quelqu'un je crois que c'était rocard
qui disait ça faut reprendre sa part est
en fait si je pense que même si on ne
change pas le monde on est vite
peut-être qu'ils deviennent pires
et puisqu'on a fait quand même ce qu'on
a vu c'est des gens se remettent de boue
des gens se remettent de boue ou des
gens sortir de la misère où des gens se
sentir accueilli des gens se sentir
reconnus et ça c'est quelque chose de
dire enfin sable et qu'on ne peut même
pas traduire tellement c'est de l'ordre
de l'ineffable quoi c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire quoi donc hollande
vous diriez vous aux autres engagez vous
absolument c'est normal armée mais en
même temps on n'est pas prosélyte ou
n'ai pas à dire tu devrais venir
oh là là tu fais rien de ta vie etc non
je pense que c'est de l'ordre du
témoignage et notre notre engagement
c'est à dire que c'est en nous voyant
vive que d'autres gens peuvent avoir
envie de faire et on l'a vu ça se faire
effectivement mais c'est pas de l'ordre
de de dire il faut il faut c'est pas de
l'ordre du volontarisme il faut que
vraiment les gens se sentent eux animé
de l'intérieur voilà moi ce qui me reste
steam ce qui me réjouit c'est que je
vois arriver des jeunes dans le no
partenaires utopia 56 qui se préoccupent
de l'accueil des mineurs isolés
étrangers à tour ils ont 30 ans et ça
c'est fabuleux
ils sont une dizaine à va être vraiment
très très impliqué et ça que je me dis
on peut mourir
ils s'envoient lie à la relève